[Música]
a raíz de la pandemia uno de los
fenómenos que enfrenta el mercado tiene
que ver con los problemas financieros de
las compañías de Aviación comercial que
en muchos casos siguen luchando por
recuperarse de las pérdidas económicas y
sin opciones las aerolíneas pequeñas
muchas veces también terminan absorbidas
por las más grandes esto crea la
situación de un monopolio y deja Sin
Control los precios para Los viajeros
sobre este tema y las implicaciones que
puede tener vamos a conversar con
Ricardo del piano analista de transporte
aéreo cientista político e historiador y
también director de contenido de
aeronaves Punto Com también se unirá en
segundos a esta conversación nuestra
editora de economía Daniela Blandón
Mientras tanto señor del piano los
saluda a ustedes Bienvenido a directo a
América
muy buenos días Muchas gracias por estar
en el programa vamos a comenzar hablando
del caso en Colombia de Avianca y de
viva Air porque las autoridades
reguladoras han sorteado este fenómeno Y
decidieron aprobar que exista una fusión
por parte de Avianca a esta aerolínea de
bajo costo pero con ciertas condiciones
Cuáles son las consecuencias de permitir
este tipo de fusiones
A ver primero hay que Añadir que la
industria aérea viene en un proceso de
consolidación que no es nuevo esto es
una continuación de un proceso que ya
viene desde hace prácticamente hace
varias décadas probablemente desde el
año noventa donde hemos visto una serie
de fusiones de integraciones de
distintos ámbitos o sea tenemos de la
consolidaciones más sencillas como puede
ser un acuerdo de códigos compartidos un
acuerdo interlineal hasta la más
compleja que son con una una fusión como
tal o un acuerdo de negocio conjunto que
es la nueva tendencia que está viendo la
industria Y entonces esto es un proceso
que no es nuevo aparece la pandemia sino
que se refuerza básicamente por el hecho
de buscar fortal en la industria aérea
ante los ciclos
económicos negativos que son más
frecuentes producto de la multipolaridad
de factores que propias del concierto
internacional que estaba que afecta
actualmente Claro pero esto puede traer
grandes consecuencias para nosotros los
usuarios y dicho esto la bienvenida
también para Daniela blanndone Daniela
tiene la palabra Ángela Muchas gracias y
continuando un poco también con la
pregunta de Ángela cuando no hay
competencia o cuando se reduce la
competencia no solamente en el sector
aéreo sino en todos los sectores pues lo
que tiende a ver es aumento de precios y
ya lo hemos visto entonces estas
aerolíneas quedan con ciertas
frecuencias en las que van a tener un
100% de del mercado Cómo hacer entonces
qué podemos esperar nosotros los
usuarios
menos compañías aéreas hemos visto que
Estados Unidos por ejemplo si bien ha
habido integraciones por ejemplo han
aparecido nuevos competidores que están
que están ingresando al mercado tenemos
el caso de Prince airways tenemos el
caso de abuelo y hay otras compañías
pequeñas en Latinoamérica apareció por
ejemplo el mismo Colombia apareció
ultraer que si bien Hoy está alude a un
problema financieros hay un proceso de
indemnización que está de ingreso que
estaría Jet Smart estaría ingresando a
Colombia Entonces el mercado se va a
reacomodando Obviamente que sí en
algunos casos puede haber situaciones
puntuales y ahí el rol del estado es
fundamental básicamente el Estado a
través de sus instituciones tiene que
ser garante de que la libre competencia
se mantenga y que exista barreras de
entrada para nuevos operadores claro
usted hablaba de que no es un caso
aislado también hay muchos otros casos
de integraciones tenemos por ejemplo en
Estados Unidos la integración que
quieren hacer JetBlue y Spirit Airlines
y el gobierno de Estados Unidos se ha
opuesto a esta integración precisamente
por este tema y hay algo Hay un
ingrediente adicional Y es que se están
fusionando en este caso una aerolínea
que no es de bajo costo con una
aerolínea que si es de bajo costo
entonces
Qué peligros hay de que una aerolínea
que es grande que tiene gran
concentración de Mercado se ve una con
una que es de bajo costo puede
desaparecer ese bajo costo para la gente
es básicamente A diferencia de de casa
estaba cuando había una gran diferencia
una lega en una compañía grande por
ejemplo lo que era tradicional como una
Legacy cardias y una de bajo costo hoy
básicamente son modelos complementarios
básicamente todas las líneas aéreas
funcionan con un esquema de bajo costo
en un solo servicios complementarios que
son los auxiliares que es básicamente
todo lo que se pagará el extra entonces
básicamente grandes diferencias no hay
entre sí puede haber entonces la fusión
entre dos tipos de compañías con dos
modelos de negocio básicamente Es un
complemento como parte de una de
segmentación del mercado y la idea de
abarcar más distintos tipos de Mercado
de tipo tipos de demanda básicamente
claro Ricardo pero si uno hace la
comparación del caso por ejemplo que
tenemos más cercano que es el de
Colombia
hoy si usted va a comprar un tiquete en
una aerolínea como Avianca es muy
distinto el costo que va a asumir
si compra en una aerolínea como vivadero
como Ultra que son denominadas de bajo
costo entonces ahí le pregunto van a
desaparecer
las hoy llamadas aerolíneas de bajo
costo Aunque entiendo lo que me dice que
claro las aerolíneas grandes también
ahora cada vez que usted agrega algo más
a su viaje pues le van cobrando Así es
por eso no hay mucha diferencia No no es
de que vayan a desaparecer De hecho yo
creo que el modelo de bajo costo Va a
continuar y se va el modelo y se va a
intensificar básicamente porque los
usuarios Están prefiriendo como de qué
servicios quieren pagar y en ese sentido
por eso la tendencia de la misa aérea
apunta a moverse más a esta esta
propuesta de bajo costo como se la
conoce y que todas las heridas paguen
por los servicios o sea por los que los
usuarios por los servicios que deseen
consumir Así que independiente que cada
una pueda ofrecer algún servicio
adicional ahora respecto al tema de los
del precio de los pasajes de ciertos es
una es una realidad actual y que no
solamente está presente en Colombia
también lo vemos en los Estados Unidos
lo vemos en Chile en Argentina y eso
responde al alto costo que está teniendo
la industria aérea en estos momentos
está factor combustible el lazo de Los
costos laborales la cadena de
suministros entonces hay una serie de
factores en paralelo que no guarda
relaciones necesariamente con las
fusiones con estas con los procesos de
consolidación que se están dando a cabo
ahora insisto el rol del estado de
fundamental y en eso las instituciones
tienen que ser claves y deben ser
imparciales en garantizar la libre
competencia para todos los actores del
mercado así como los nuevos actores que
quieran ingresar obviamente la el
escenario de la industria aérea se
vuelve mucho más desafiante vamos a
tener una serie de condiciones paralelas
y el entorno que nos obliga a contar más
recursos o contar mayores recursos para
poder funcionar el caso Quizás El de
ultraer puede ser un ejemplo de ello que
una compañía nueva que nació después de
la pandemia o después de la
restricciones mejor dicho
y hoy enfrenta problemas económicos
Ricardo y hablando de los problemas
económicos Avianca por ejemplo tiene
problemas económicos están en un proceso
de reorganización no solamente en
Colombia sino también en Estados Unidos
Cómo podemos
Cómo podemos describir la situación la
salud del de la industria aérea porque
me da la sensación de que nos podemos
estar despidiendo de esos viajes
económicos que tuvimos durante tantos
años con esta con esta
Renacimiento de las aerolíneas de bajo
costo llegó el final digamos de esa de
esa viajes baratos para la gente
los viajes baratos que conocimos hace un
par de años responde primero a la
búsqueda de pasajeros que después de la
serie de restricciones Cuando nadie
quería volar y la demanda estaba muy
baja Obviamente que era muy fácil y
había algunos pasajes muy económicos Y
eso es una realidad después de los 2020
lo vimos en el 2021 y generó una
explosiva demanda eso
sin duda yo creo una tendencia que se va
a acabar que se va a acabar en cuanto a
ese contexto ahora los viajes esto el
tema de los viajes económicos también
asociados al al periodo que estamos
escribiendo como como industria el que
guarda el concepto mundial lo que
hablaba antes el tema de los alza el
precio de combustible el
Los costos laborales la inflación la
devaluación de las monedas locales
frente al Dólar entonces esa historia
que nos van imponiendo costos a que
imponen costoso que al final termina
pagando los clientes también el tema de
la carga impositiva eso es un punto muy
que no es menor en sobre todo en
Latinoamérica Entonces tenemos una serie
de factores adicionales que que ojalá
los gobiernos pudieran hacer trabajar en
una agenda Pro Aviación o prueba o Pro
desarrollo económico donde incluyan el
transporte aéreo y como como una es como
el
como una industria de aporte
Pues bien nos hemos quedado sin tiempo
gracias a ustedes Ricardo por
entregarnos sus puntos de vista y su
análisis de lo que podría ser una
situación complicada para las aerolíneas
y para la industria aeronáutica gracias
a usted Daniela también les recuerdo
estuvo con nosotros Ricardo del piano en
la lista de transporte aéreo cientista
político e historiador vamos a hacer una
pequeña pausa y ya regresamos con más de
directo América
[Música]